[Music]
am I in focus
[Music]
hi guys
so I'm gonna try and do more vlogging
things and I'm usually like oh I should
only blog you know when I'm doing
something super cool um but no most of
the time I'm alone I'm just alone in my
room doing loads of random stuff but I
mean I'm going to uni today but anyway
so I just figured I would show you an
actual day in my life you know a lazy
day cold day snowy day it's actually
snowing right now and they're supposed
to be snowing all week I think we're
just crazy cuz it's March is it much no
it's pretty much March and it's it's
snowing so um yeah follow me around
oh and I have a deadline today my
lecture is gonna be looking at the game
I'm really worried I haven't enough of
those you don't know I'm going to
university studying computer game arts
and I'm making my third-year game but
I'm making all I got walk to games it's
like supposed to be ready narratively
driven and scary and spooky and bah bah
there's so many elements to it so much
cold but it's okay I'll see what he says
we'll see what he says oh my god I hope
I don't blog being told off by my
lecturer look at the snow go girl look
at snow okay time for breakfast I gonna
leave the house in half an hour
it's still snowy I'm sick I'm so good
because it will wake start and stop no
that's for Aboriginal no flour um what
was he saying yeah time to make
breakfast much okay I gotta get rid of
this little smudge
honey can coffee coffee is what I need
is hoppy impoverish after death you
always have dead flowers we put them to
the Sun because I don't think they're
getting enough Sun but then we're in
England and look it's just snowing it's
it's not getting any Sun there either
look it's never going to they're never
gonna get better
can you see the snow out there I'll show
you a proper shot I love first I have to
walk out in this snow for half an hour
soon so I'm sure you'll get to see that
soon look at it look at it it's just
gonna go in a gun this is getting
crazier crazier crazier yeah I'm going
but here's where I'm at with the
porridge so far I need to get ready I'm
gonna fit I'm gonna put you down our
boiler has been broken
longest time and my landlord just
refuses to just like thinks that
anything's wrong he just he just refuses
to believe it and just leaves the
situation this is proof
just been told I don't need to be an uni
for another hour but I'm gonna leave
soon but I just keep looking at the snow
and I'm like it's pretty but it's minus
1 degrees such a lonely day and it's
mine the most loneliest day of my haha
I'm such a lonely day should be bad it's
a day that I can stay
[Music]
I am I
yes I did it
I am upside down oh I always get like
how do I do that
it's gonna be the weirdest I said I've
probably already done five minutes
photos of just me getting ready to leave
the house hi I am going to go to uni
doesn't I finally made it home
rushing light makes everything very
dramatic I guess I thought I was safe
left the house the snow had stopped it
seemed like it was gonna be an easy ball
but as I walked the snow got thicker I
think turned into a blizzard
drenching my hair making my fingers turn
white and I also saw guys fishing on the
way what my bunny in uni anyway so
that's show my lecture my game still so
much to do on it before we go carry on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
photograph I need to start to wait we're
finally out of uni yeah it's really cold
so we're gonna go and brace the code
again but we showed our game to people
and I was worried because I was like oh
but I went okay Junaid yeah we got some
really good feedback and then we got to
see everyone else's games and now I'm
ready to eat
I'm really hungry so called Euler Masham
sushi welcome to the Logan Paul's
Channel today we're gonna do some stupid
sure dab on them haters you have men's
Devon yes
[Laughter]
don't laugh me I'm getting on that vlog
like all the greens and the purple and
the white and the red brown yeah I like
carrots we have carrots can I use a
carrot animate I have been needing this
I don't know why I'm shaking I use food
I hate this have an item so that's how
fast ate and usually at this time
don't judge me I'm just chilling I just
get a bit like I don't know what to do
myself I'm like should I start working
on a YouTube video or show do some more
work for uni or should I answer some
emails or show do some extracurricular
work or shall I do work for work work
work watch the play game what should I
sing or should I try and do some
gymnastics because it's too early for
bed but all I want to do so nicely maybe
I should do some work what kind of work
- no I'm just hi guys it's half eight
the bedtime no no go bad in like two
hours so I don't fall asleep I've
decided to get up to my workstation this
is my workstation I'm gonna sit here if
I'm around my work stuff then I'll
probably actually do some work so do
work you lazy poo yeah my motivational
message my little cute octopus I mean
one of those like overwhelming roots why
I want to do a bit of everything I'm
just like I get one idea then I'm like
nobody's doing nothing I need to see
sound should probably do this Wow
I kind of just want to draw right now
let me get my little sketch pad boom
knees so it's a heart and a brain if you
can't tell and I wanted to start for the
bottom heart I wanted to start doing a
little mini-series on Instagram
documenting the battle between the brain
and the heart I don't know when the
heart is suffering and the brain is
looking after it or just giving it
telling off like this is all you're
doing anyway heart well you look so
stupid if I say I want to do that but
then you know I'm always like oh if I'm
going system arm work it should probably
be something towards my game because we
don't have we don't really have a
concept artist for the game so we're all
just trying to do little bits of art as
we go along
I get like these crazy creative bursts
crazy energetic Barriss and I never know
when they're gonna come or how long
they're gonna last
sometimes they can last for a while and
I won't need to sleep I can I can only
have a few hours
couple hours and I'm fine and I'm just
like go go go and I'm so like yeah I can
do anything
and then suddenly I just like run into a
wall and I'm like wolf and I just fall
over I'm like I can't do any and all my
energy goes and I think I'm nearing that
crush date it might be a minute I'm just
so tired now I think especially my
deadline I'm just like oh it's done if a
life is never finished is there you've
always soon as you've got one thing
completed you've got to start working
any other things um it just it just gets
too much and I'm just like I really just
want to break from all sometimes I just
want to delete every app on my phone
just live in the wilderness for a bit
but this is my problem as a person
because I want to be online doing this
fun stuff and I love technology and love
making games I love making films and
then there's a part way that's crying
out and I'm just like no I just want to
live in the woods surrounded by chickens
with not a care in the world and no
internet and that's no I'm just rambling
now but maybe I can make it work I don't
know I'll find out a way I have my
business in the woods maybe a cabin in
the woods and that'll be my business of
like making games and films with a
handful of other people and then we
watch the Lord of the Rings trilogy
while we're working
and then we listen to the Lord of the
Rings soundtrack I'm I'm really obsessed
with all the Rings at the moment I don't
know why but it's not even like Lord of
the Rings I'm not actually watching the
films actually no I did watch fellowship
but I am listening to the soundtrack all
the time and I'm watching every single
documentary and behind the scenes that I
can find even of The Hobbit camera is
about to die as well so this is perfect
so thank you so much for all your
support and just little things like you
guys making me like little pictures and
you from the streams or something like
that and I tweeted out a picture the
other day I was like someone told me
super Sayan and you did and is freaking
awesome and I love the heart of oh I
deserve that you guys are creative and
passionate
and just lovely I'm so sorry that I
can't speak to you guys individually
I'm it'll be amazing if I could but I
can't and I want to make sure that I
don't like single anyone out you know I
don't really give someone more attention
than so on Alice because you're all
awesome
so you know thank you I can't say thank
you enough hope this wasn't too boring
this is literally an average day in my
life is kind of what happens you might
go to uni do some work come back moan
about what I've got to do and think
about what I've got to do and play a
ukulele derivative headstands I I get
bored very easily that guitar so achene
I haven't really been practicing guitar
enough I need to do that more see this
this is my mind like you need to do this
one no you need to do this more don't
tell me what to do
we all talk to ourselves over
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi hello hi hi hi okay I know I said I
was gonna get bad like ages ago and this
happens to the best of us you know one
sec oh it's go sorry it's gonna die I
need to you
it's um what time is it it's nearly
midnight for me
[Music]
that's pretty look at that
like that's gorgeous that's pretty look
at that that's gorgeous it's actually a
new day that's no blog anyway the other
day I thought I'd show you this cuz it's
actually gotten super snowy like lychee
I don't even need I'm just sliding down
I don't even need to take steps right
now so we've decided to go for an
explore you say whatever the heck you
want basically we're in the snow
and it's fun there's doggy do you want
to see AG slip no someone like you can
be in the vlog vlog it's a blog blog on
the rock not the rock though tree trunk
yeah no but you know it's bigger than a
beam it's also I see okay to see your
face oh my god I'm not doing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]